here are 10 tips to engage your readers
encourage them to read more of the
content and help you monetize your news
app 1 listen to your readers feedback
and analyze their behavior read and
reply to app reviews in the Google Play
Developer console and use Google
Analytics to measure and analyze user
behavior to help you find where they
disengage this will help you modify your
app to encourage engagement to know your
readers with sign-in so you can better
engage them Google sign-in is a secure
authentication system that reduces the
burden of login for your users by
enabling them to sign in with their
Google account the same account they
already use with Gmail play Google+ and
other Google services even on iOS and
desktop once a reader has signed in you
can personalize the experience 3 help
readers to rediscover your app with
notifications help readers rediscover
your app using breaking news and content
update rich notifications make sure you
provide readers with control over what
and when they're notified so they can
keep up with the news that matters to
them for build monetization strategies
that meet your readers expectations you
can choose from using subscriptions to
offer premium features or content
selling a paid app on Google Play
using a one-off in-app purchase to offer
premium features or content or gaining
ad revenue such as from display ads from
your inventory with double-click for
publishers
five mix-and-match billing models to
capture more reader's loyalty use in-app
purchases to offer one-off content or
premium features for example providing a
special one-off news report as an audio
podcast for a one-off payment is a great
way to capture your readers using ads
will also help to boost your revenue 6
optimize your subscription price
proposition for your readers if you
decide on a subscription model offer
subscriptions that appeal to readers
interests encouraging commitment through
scale pricing and make sure they're
available on all of the readers devices
options include weekly monthly quarterly
every six months and annual
differentiate entry pricing
significantly from the normal
subscription to keep the entry barrier
low for example by progressively
discounting longer running subscriptions
7 utilize promotional features of Google
Play billing to increase your subscriber
conversion use promo codes and goodwill
credits to reward loyal subscribers of
your premium paid content offer
subscribers the ability to upgrade and
capture lower spenders by introducing
them to lower priced offers 8 utilize
free trials to increase subscribers
using Google Play billing you can offer
readers a free trial and customize the
time period so that it works for your
business for example 5 7 30 or 60 days
when readers sign up to the free trial
they enter their payment details so if
they don't cancel the subscription
they'll turn into regular paying
subscribers once the free trial is
complete
9 understand your users behavior and
subscription patterns use the Google
Play Developer console to track user
acquisition this provides funnel
reporting covering store listing visits
installs purchases and repeat purchases
it also includes user 2 by our
conversion reporting these reports let
you visualize how your different
audiences compare in other words track
your progress in terms of conversion
rates they also provide a conversion as
a function of time you'll see when
customer retention is starting to
plateau they'll help you identify where
you have the biggest drop-offs and where
you can improve 10 maximize revenue from
your ad inventory with double-click for
publishers you can deliver ads to all
your digital touch points desktop mobile
web and your app then use the
marketplace offered by double-click Ad
Exchange to acquire inventory from many
leading advertisers head over to Google
Play Developer console to start taking
advantage of these features if you want
more tips on how to improve your news
apps and build a better mobile business
check out the other videos in this
series and download the news publishers
playbook